rella tutti i ragazzi e benvenuti a
questo nuovo io sono felice oggi siamo
su un nuovo blog ma non è un blog
normale perché ormai i blog normali non
ne faccio più dal non so quanto tempo
per il semplice fatto che l'otto
dicembre quindi un paio di giorni fa è
stato il quarto compleanno del mio
canale ho deciso ed è una cosa che non
avevo ancora fatto di fare una top ten
dei miei video più belli prima di
lanciare questa top ten meravigliosa
volevo farvi vedere un'altra roba allora
youtube questo bellissimo sito dove
carichi i v day ha pubblicato l'altro
giorno la top ten dei video più visti in
italia del 2016 ma eletta ragazzi hanno
creato due classifiche perché hanno
fatto la classifica dei dieci video
musicali più visti e poi hanno fatto la
classifica dei dieci mido non musicali
più visti e indovinate ragazzi che è
arrivato al terzo posto tra tutti i
video più visti in italia
prova a non ridere challenge video che
ho fatto in 15 minuti in croce perché
non sapevo che cazzo registrare visto
che l'aveva fatto anche mio nonno dentro
c'è una prova non ridere challenge 3
milioni di views al secondo posto dei
video più visti in italia abbiamo scusa
[Musica]
c'è la classifica dei video musicali e
c'è quella dei video non musicali giobbi
youtube e quindi ragazzi adesso passiamo
alla top ten dei video che preferisco
del mio canale questa classifica non è
fatta per i video più visti del mio
canale noi che vado su popolari qui che
voglio vedere i primi dieci che sono
questi anche perché il mio sesto video
più visto in assoluto cia tipo 4 milioni
di views ed e maltratta la tua ex che è
uscito quando mi sono lasciato quindi ha
fatto un miliardo di visualizzazioni
solo per questo motivo perché io facevo
click bait prima che lo facessero tutti
quanti sucate le palle avete notato
quanto basti far vedere una [ __ ] in in
copertina di un video per farle views
c'è veramente incredibile st robben top
ten dei video più belli che ho fatto
secondo me c'è ebrei rom
mi è piaciuto un sacco perché per questa
cosa
[Musica]
ogni volta che lo guardo riguardo questo
primo pezzo è bellissimo perché se li
faccio io e lui si caga addosso e
bellissimo cos'era questo ragazzi era la
posizione numero 10 perché era uno dei
primi video un po diversi che ho provato
a fare sul canale perché non era proprio
un videogioco
io penso da quella parte dove dovete il
più di questa nuova bene che questo
video geniale ma è sicuramente uno dei
più belli ci siamo mai usciti
chiaramente fighissimo vabbè decimo
posto ragazzi ne mancano altri nove
andiamo veloci sui primi così a meno
stringiamo stringiamo vabbè ma bruna e
colloquio di lavoro fa vj abbiamo
improvvisato con con sky questo
colloquio di lavoro finto ovviamente per
poter fare promozione a un'attività che
stanno facendo appunto con sky sono
fatto dare il girato perché fa veramente
scarso è veramente bellissimo noi sono
guardate 800 volte soprattutto sta parte
e ha doti di flessibilità serietà
concretezza impegno capacità di motivare
gli altri
tra i problemi guardi cosa so fare
inflessibilità mi riprendo questa è
stata la sua reazione spontanea
purtroppo number set
in questo video vecchio ma può un
vecchio vecchio però ma dj bungee
jumping queste ragazze il blog della
settimana scorsa è niente non l'ho
riguardato 800 volte perché quando rigua
allora il fatto è che mi sono pagato
dalle 20 in mano che riguardare la
performance mimì mimì fa eccitare non so
come faccia nel senso motivo e mi hanno
scritto fa vice i due palle giganti
problema è che non è vero non so come
cazzo fatto da un momento di pazzia
sapete quanta [ __ ] o rimorchiato questo
video in una settimana
forse il mio cuscino questo video
ragazzi e tra l'altro a 4 milioni di
visualizzazioni uno dei più visti del
mio canale private ogni scena che vede
fin subito secondo me vale un video
quindi è del tipo questa che ho potuto
lama che ha un poliziotto non vi dirò
mai come è finita questa cosa perché
tutti mi hanno chiesto ma continuerò a
fare il misterioso anche perché la mia e
mi ha detto di stare zitto andiamo
ragazzi alla top 5 4 ma questa è la
numero 7
che cazzo di posizione di mi chiama
neanche a fare una classifica la
posizione 17 che cosa ho detto io
posizione meno 6 numero 7 77 scusata
posizione numero sei adesso siamo alla
semin che neanche fare una top ten 1
youtuber di merda quasi 06 coca cola
gomorra quando ho provato ragazza e
creare una coca cola gommosa mi è venuto
spontaneo provare a fare un video del
genere perché avevo visto che stanno
impazzando in rete sta roba e dovete
sapere che io ho sempre fatto schifo
negli art attack sceglie da piccolo
prova a fare gli attacchi non me ne è
uscito mai neanche uno ma neanche uno
isabeau volanti cristo degli art attack
insomma ho provato quindi a fare sta
coca cola gommosa che è uscita che cazzo
ne problemi che non vi dico per pulire
madonna lo schifo che è dovuta venire
mia madre da torino per pulire una merda
per terra poi avete visto solo
l'inquadratura ma fuori
dall'inquadratura era un casino di
bottiglie posate pentole schizzi ovunque
non pensate male
arriviamo né vi do un po più vecchi ma
che secondo me meritano la top five sono
gli avrei messi in top five sono un
[ __ ] geneva vj animated un video
fosse uno dei più corti del mio canale
sono il più corto addirittura dura due
minuti e 13 ed e voi non avete idea di
quanto tempo ci abbiamo messo a fare
cristo video perché poi è stato un
gruppo di ragazzi che ancora ringrazio
che ha fatto il suo lavoro si è fatto un
buco di culo così ha fatto questa
animazione su di me contro i miei
acerrimi nemici che sono sono il tipo di
amnesia il manichino che mario è la tipo
di de grazia è ovviamente slider man e
io mi sono alzato da questa sedia e lì
ho fatto il buco del culo così sono
messo due anni per far questo video è
uscito 6 settembre 2015 ed era in
programma più o meno dal settembre 2013
più o meno due anni per farlo però la
posizione numero 4 ragazzi abbiamo
[Musica]
li visualizza corrisponde bruciare i
boys ei forni a microonde lo sapete
ragazzi questa frase me l'hanno usata
anche contro una volta una persona che
ha scritto ti brucerei vivo in sei forni
a microonde perché non le rispondevo è
visualizzato e basta che cosa sono i
maroni e lucia sapessi sapessi arriviamo
ragazzi alla tanto agognata top xishun
l'agognata e tipo la cognata solo che
con l'agi alla number free quindi coppa
di bronzo coppa di stronzo per face
league
raramente rigori guardando i miei video
perché lì registro ci metto un orali
monto e ci metto 5 ore 4 ore dipende dai
tipi di video 3 anche vorrei difendere
su due non li monto io lo scherzo ci
mette una vita mezza lontani quindi li
conosco a memoria difficile che
riguardandoli io rida
ma questo riguardandolo ancora adesso
che figata ragazzi che figata non lo so
io sono uno che nei propri risultati e
molto critico e cioè non è che adesso vi
guardano i video di qua come timoniere
tuttofare questa è proprio una top ten
dei video che veramente preferisco
perché i generi non me li riguardo i
miei video ma questi mi chiama
riguardare la vita posizione numero 2
abbiamo credo che oltre a essere uno dei
video più belli questo credo sia uno dei
più significativi vede my life ii the
raw mylife ragazzi ha fatto ha
totalizzato di polmonite 2.700.000 views
quando io ho fatto questo video era per
lo speciale 45 mila iscritti e il primo
video nel quale io mi sono messo a
parlare davvero con voi nel senso che io
prima registravo gameplay ma non lo
faccio vedere lorenzo nei video adesso
capita raramente pro capite abita più
caldo non e video dove sono incazzato
quindi bella roba per riprendere
dall'alto così come state vedendo avevo
messo la webcam quindi questa così e per
farlo avevo attaccato al muro una trave
che era niente popò di meno che un
righello e ci aveva appoggiato la webcam
sopra così rimaneva a testa in giù
proprio professional youtube inc come
diventare famosi con un righello e non
vi azzardate a tocca legno goku quanto
mi hai fatto paura da un [ __ ]
quindi ragazzi siamo arrivati alla
posizione number one del video più bello
che secondo me è uscito il mio canale è
la cross bar challenge playmates questo
video a parte il fatto che dura sei
minuti quindi relativamente poco ma per
montarlo ci ho messo una giornata erano
tipo 2 ore di riprese perché ovviamente
le attraversano le beccavamo e quasi mai
tranne la prima volta che vi giuro su
dio questa guerra la prima volta che
calciava in porta e per quano non si sa
quale venne edizione di pina ho beccato
la traversa non so come forse sarò io
veramente quello che sarà sarà visto più
volte in assoluto avrò visto mille volte
almeno riducendo anche se abbastanza
recente perché luglio 2016
però secondo me morì più belli
aversa che non ho assolutamente
preservato bene è vero non la prese
scusa papa ragazzi miei questa era la
top ten di vidor che che ho fatto che
preferisco io erano top ten personale
voglio dirvi che nel mentre che stiamo
facendo questo video è venuta questa
incredibile idea però un sondaggio
chiedendovi quali sono qual è secondo
voi il video più bello e io ho fatto sul
sul mio canale prenderò poi la top ten
dei video che voterebbe di più e ci farò
un altro video sopra commentando i video
più belli che secondo voi sono usciti
sul canale andate sulla pagina di
facebook che vi lascio di iscrizione a
right now che ho fatto uscire un
sondaggio sul video secondo voi qual è
il video più bello che ho fatto uscire
sul canale andate a votare il vostro
preferito qua sotto vieterà caso di dire
che possono chiudere qui il video vi
ringrazio per avermi seguito in questi
quattro anni che sono stati wow se vi
sia piaciuto ragazzino ha subito
lasciato commento è un mi piace anche a
pagina di facebook che ogni lottatore
descrizione allestiti siete ci vediamo
al prossimo video dei ragazzi